guten Morgen Frau Giffey wie geht's dir
hier in
Berlin nach Berlin sie haben direkt den
ersten Witz gemacht finde ich gut
Berlin hier stecken Autos rund 71
Stunden pro Jahr im Stau die wichtigsten
Bahnlinien sind aktuell gesperrt aber
hey dafür darf man zweimal wählen ich
finde es super ich persönlich liebe
Berlin das sagen mir ganz viele Leute
weil ich wohne in Köln und Berlin ist
die einzige Stadt die mich glauben lässt
können wäre schön
wirklich ich erlebe viele Menschen die
mir dann doch so sagen ach ist eine
ähnliches Berlin schon eine tolle Stadt
ne kommt man schon gern her trotz allem
trotzdem ist ja das Schöne in Berlin
nichts funktioniert und das soll meiner
Meinung nach auch so bleiben damit der
Rest Deutschland was zu lachen hat
deswegen möchte ich ja Wahlkampf für sie
machen kann ich auf den Straßen
unterwegs sein was muss ich sagen wie
kann ich die Leute überzeugen Berlin
Punkt an ganz vielen Stellen
für die SPD
also ich mache heute Wahlkampf für
Franziska Giffey weil ich mir denke
Berlin als dysfunktionale Stadt muss als
Weltkulturerbe erhalten bleiben ja und
das ist für mich einfach sehr angenehm
dass ich morgens aufwache sehe aber
Wiederholungen in Berlin ich mache auf a
ein Aquarium mit tausenden Fischen ist
geplatzt es ist einfach jeden Tag gibt
es eine neue Meldung aus Berlin wir
geben uns natürlich immer Mühe ein
bisschen was zu bieten für den Rest des
Landes
Lichtenrade sieht nicht aus wie Berlin
gehört aber wohl dazu Straßenwahlkampf
ich wollte dir ein paar Flyer von mir
geben und die kannst du verteilen was
ist denn auch Berliner Abiturniveau
geschrieben nee leichte Sprache
verständlich
also ja ja nein Quatsch hier nehmen Sie
ruhig alle die die ich nämlich mal ein
Kugelschreiber nicht mal ein
Kugelschreiber ich will da privat doch
auch nicht mit gesehen werden wir müssen
ja Heizkosten sparen vielleicht könnte
man damit ein kleines Lagerfeuer
entzünden oder so ich habe mich noch
nicht entschieden für keine Parteien
dann bitte Franziska Giffey wählen weil
nachher kommt sie noch zurück in die
Bundespolitik das kann niemand wollen
also sie beide wählen Franziska gefallen
ne ich habe sie überzeugt auf jeden Fall
schön vom Aussehen die Frau gefällt mir
ja die Frau gefällt mir ne ja Alter
schlagen genau
[Musik]
das ist jetzt ein historischer Moment
hier für Berlin Franziska Giffey legt
den Grundstein für Berlins erstes
funktionierendes Wahllokal sind
Gänsehautmoment wir sind halt nicht
bullerbüt ne und meckern ist leicht aber
was besser machen da müssen alle ein
bisschen sich bemühen und das ist der
Punkt an dem ich gerne arbeiten
sie werden mit Berlins bärenstarker
Verwaltung da kann ich mich auch gleich
Doktor nennen ohne Doktortitel zu haben
mit 40.000 Kolleginnen und Kollegen in
der Berliner Verwaltung die hier im Job
machen ich kann es nicht akzeptieren
dass man generell sagt das ist sind
alles Leute die hier sich nicht für
diese Stadt engagieren das hier tausende
von Wohnungen gerade gebaut werden wir
sind hier an einem Projekt das ist das
moderne
um Termin zu kriegen also wenn man sich
jetzt für die Wohnung die hier gebaut
wird anmelden will da hätte man ja 2018
schon Termin zum ummelden machen
Deutschland Sie innerhalb von heute auf
morgen den Wohnungsbau hinkriegen
eigentlich gefragt warum man in Berlin 8
Wochen auf einen Termin beim Amt wartet
aber egal am Ende des Tages wollen wir
ja alle das gleiche hauptsache die
anderen Kunden an ne der grüne Vogel
das wäre das Schlimmste für uns wer ist
der grüne Vogel
die die Jahres ist der grüne ja ja eine
private Frage habe ich noch ich würde
mich gern ich würde mich gerne für den
Berlin Marathon am 12 Februar anmelden
wo kann ich das machen
wir haben keinen Marathon am 12 Februar
aber sie können gerne im April beim
Halbmarathon mitlaufen ich fange sie
dann auch auf wenn Sie ein
Schwächeanfall kriegen sollten oder so
dann bin ich da und tut für ihn die
Stirn aber am 12 Februar konzentrieren
wir uns mal voll dass sie bei gut läuft
ja okay viel Glück danke schön
tschüss tschüss ja und nach diesen
Eindrücken aus Berlin freue ich mich
sogar wieder auf Köln und damit zurück
ins Studio
schaut euch gerne weitere Videos an und
abonniert den Kanal danke
oh nein eine Zeitschleife habt ihr etwa
nicht den Kanal abonniert Hilfe sofort
draufklicken oder ich bin hier für immer
schaut euch gerne weitere Videos an